lele pêcheur Guy Larochelle viet
tataquiner le poissonau pied
dede la fonderie Horne.
I Il utilise comme appât
unun marcheur de fond.
GUGUY LAROCHELLE pêcheur
etet v.-p. Collectif Territoire
- - Ça c'est une bonne méthode
popour le doré.
- - Le gouvernement recommande
dede ne pas manger plus de deux
rerepas de doré par mois provent
dede ce lac, contrairement
auaux autres lacs de la région.
- - Une étude de 2015 indique
quque les concentrations de métx
lolourds dans leles se diments
dudu lac Osisko dépassent les
coconcentrations recommandées
popour protéger les organismes
aqaquatiques.
- - C'esest un résidu qui ressee
àà une poussière noire, qui est
trtrès, très soluble dans l'eau.
IlIl y en a à peu près 30 cm
d'd'épais, mais si on passe note
mamain là-dedans, ça va
sese dissiper comme un nuage.
- - Radio-Canada a parcouru
plplusieurs études portant
susur l'impact sur la faune
etet la flore de la Fonderie
HoHorne, propriété de Glencore.
D Des chercheurs se sont penchs
susur le lichehen. L'étude démoe
quque l'accumulation des métaux
lolourds dans le lichen est
enen cours et non seulement
lele r résultat du passé.
JEJÉRÉMY DUPONT, chercheur UQAM
- - Le plomb on l'a retrouvé 150
fofois plus élevé à la proximité
dede la fonderie que ce qu'on
reretrouvait à 50 km dans le bo.
- - Il en va aussi du nickel
etet du cadmium, dont on retroue
dedes traces jusqu'à 50 km
àà l'est.
- - Ça nous aiguille sur le fait
quque ça vient très probablement
dede la fonderie, mais assurémet
dede la ville de Rouyn Noranda.
- - Le Conseil en environnement
dede la région souhaite que le
gogouvernement accentue les
exexigences quant aux contanimas
rerejetés par la mine.
CLCLÉMENTINE CORNILLE, DG, Consl
enenvironnement, Abitibi-Témisc.
- - Elle est seulement normée
auau niveau de l'arsenic,
mamais pour tous les autres
cocontaminants, métaux lourds
etet pour les terres rares il ya
acactuellement rien qui est pré.
EtEt ça ne fait pas partie
dudu réseau de surveillance.
- - En 45 ans, Yves et
seses partenaires de chasse
onont tué 45 bêtes.
- - Ça c'est vous là?
- - Oui.
- - Ce sont eux x qui évisérent
leleur proie.
YVYVES GINGRGRAS,
chchasseur de Rouyn-Noranda
- - Quand que le foie a des
pepetites tâches blanches dessus
onon le laisse là. Quand il n'ya
papas de tâches blanches,
onon l'amène et on le mange.
- - Au Québec, il n'est pas
rerecommandé de manger les abats
d'd'orignal, reconnus pour être
cocontaminés au cadmium.
S Selon une étude réalisé
enen 2013, les orignaux dans
unun rayon de 50 km autour de la
fofonderie ont des concentratios
bebeaucoup plus élevés de cadmim
dadans les reins que les autres
cecervidés ailleurs au Québec
etet même dans le monde..
L Les rejetets passés de
lala fonderie sont suspectés
d'd'être à l'origine.
G Glencore explique qu'au fil
dedes décennies, plusieurs projs
onont permis d'améliorer le biln
enenvironnemental.
U Un plan d'action majeur
popour réduire les émissions
atatmosphériques sera déposé
enen août.
U Un changement de cap
enenvironnemental est exigé
popour la mine, poumon économiqe
dede la région.
- J'ai confiance aussi que
çaça va aussi se faire a avec
lala mine e et avec tout le mone
alalentour, dans la région.
- - Pour que l'on puisse un jour
sese baigner à nouveau dans le c
OsOsisko
I ICI Marie-Josée Paquette-Comu
R Radio-Canada, Rouyn-Noranda